all right part b a fresh zinc air cell
is weighed on an analytical balance
before being placed in a hearing aid for
use
as the cell operates does the mass of
the cell increase decrease or remain the
same
justify your answer to part b1 or bi b1
in terms of the equation for the overall
cell reaction so let's just think about
it a little bit does the mass of the
cell increase decrease or remain the
same let's go to our original reaction
over here this is our total reaction the
zinc is part of the metal air cell
so that would contribute to its its its
weight beforehand
and then it reacts with the oxygen well
where is this oxygen coming from well
this oxygen is coming from the air and
essentially it gets incorporated into
the zinc
so before the oxygen is in the air but
then after the reaction after the total
reaction it gets incorporated with the
zinc i guess i should say not into the
zinc or it gets incorporated with the
zinc
as zinc oxide and so now the oxygen is
part of the cell
part
or contributes to weight of the cell
so contributes
contributes
to
the
weight
the weight of cell it doesn't contribute
before the reaction but contributes
after the reaction
so our the mass and i guess you could
say the weight is going to increase so
i'll just write increase
and part two
we need to justify our answer in terms
of the equation for the overall cell
reaction so let me just write the
overall cell reaction so two
zinc molecules react with one molecular
oxygen
one o2
two yield to
zinc
oxide
to zinc oxide molecules well what we
could say is is that
this was not part of cell before
reaction
not
part
of cell
before reaction is coming from the air
before reaction
and then you could say part of cell
after reaction
part
of
cell
after
reaction and we could write it out in
words if we like
after
a reaction and so i could say
oxygen
comes from air
from
from air
air to be incorporated into the zinc
oxide to be
incorporated
into
zinc
oxide which
can tr which then contributes to weight
of cell or to the mass of cell which
then contributes
to mass of cell
to
mass
of
cell all right i feel pretty good about
that now let's do part c
the zinc air cell is taken to the top of
a mountain where the air pressure is
lower
will the cell potential be higher lower
or the same as the cell potential at the
lower elevation justify your answer to
the first part based on the equation for
the overall cell reaction and the
information above
well let me just write the overall cell
reaction again so let me
the overall
cell reaction i'll rewrite it again so
we have
two
zinc molecules
let me write that a little bit neater
two
i've ordered messier two zinc
molecules one molecular oxygen we're
going to have this ingrained in our
brain by the time this is done i'm
writing it so frequently
we get two zinc oxides two
zinc
oxides
and so what's going to happen if if we
go to the top of a mountain where the
air pressure is lower we have just fewer
air molecules in general that means
we're also going to have lower oxygen
molecules so we can say that the partial
pressure of oxygen is going to be lower
so we could say
partial pressure of reactant will be
lower
partial
pressure
there's just going to be fewer oxygen
molecules from the air being able to
bump and react with the zinc molecules
well actually it's not reacting with the
zinc molecules as we saw
in the original reactions when we look
at the half reactions fewer oxygens from
the air just bumping in the right way
with the
with the with the water molecules and
actually the electrons that are coming
in through the circuit you're going to
have fewer of them bouncing around being
able to do this reaction
so you could say
partial pressure
of
reactant
or maybe i'll say partial pressure or
you could also do the concentration of
the reaction there's going to be just a
reactant there's going to be less of it
around partial pressure or we could say
concentration
lower
so
so lower cell potential
lower cell
cell potential so actually i just did it
in reverse i answered part two first and
so part one is lower so we're going to
have a lower cell potential
lower
cell
potential it's really important to get
the conceptual understanding of why it's
happening remember when we look at the
half reaction what's happening
what is happening at our cathode we have
oxygen coming in from the air and it
gets into the kind of the pores of this
porous substance and when the oxygen
the the o2 molecules bump in just the
right way with the water and the
electrons coming in they just kind of go
together
and react you get your hydroxide for
they react to form the hydroxide now if
you have less you know at a lower
elevation you're going to have a lot of
oxygen you're going to have a high
partial pressure of the molecular oxygen
so a lot of them are any moment in time
are going to be available to bounce
around and react but if you go to a
higher elevation you're just going to
have fewer of these characters so you're
going to have fewer of these characters
so you're going to have a lower partial
pressure of oxygen or you could have
think of it as you have a lower
concentration of oxygen inside the pores
so it's going to be harder for this
reaction
to move forward and you can think about
the extreme situation what if you kept
going to a super high elevation if you
eventually go into space where you have
very little oxygen or no oxygen at all
well then then the reaction is going to
stop all together so hopefully
hopefully that
that makes let me just go back to part c
here i'm having trouble my
oh
this
go back to part c
and there you go